our brains are particularly attuned to
negative responses
it
tends to absorb and brush off positive
responses but it is attuned to negative
ones because over the long history
our
brains are
wired to connect right and so it is very
sensitive when somebody rejects us
that doesn't mean we're wrong we're
broken our business sucks that we're a
loser an idiot that means that your
brain rings that bell a little bit
louder than it does the good stuff right
that's why i can get go to summit
2 500 people say it's incredible that
one person wrote a one and i want to
call them and be like listen number one
i'm gonna fight you in the parking lot
number two you're an idiot number three
can we hug them sorry right
and so i think there's something about
just talking about brain chemistry real
quick
if it yells at you acknowledge your
brain trying to take care of you and
then go thank you for ringing that bell
for me i'm not a loser i'm not an idiot
i'm whatever
i'm a good guy
i'm a
good mom i'm a good brother good sister